let me ask you a fun question
if uh hikaru and nakamura uh was one of
the two people uh what i guess i
apologize yeah he could have he could
have finished second yeah so he lost the
last round of the candidates yeah and
you uh put maybe you can explain to me
internet speak copium is something you
tweeted
yeah
but if he if he got second
would you uh would you would you
just despite him still still play the
world championship that's internet
question and when the internet asks
samus the bide the dude divides
yeah sure thank you internet
so after the last match uh i did
an
interview
uh right after where i talked about the
fact that i was unlikely to play the
next one
i'd spoken privately to both
family friends and
of course also my chess team that this
was likely going to be the last
the last match
um
what happened was that
right before the world championship
match there was this young player
already sofia he had a dramatic rise he
rose to second in the world rankings he
was 18 then nine he's 19 now he
qualified for the candidates and it felt
like there was like
at least a half realistic possibility
that
he could be
the challenger for the next world
championship
uh and that sort of lit a fire under me
um do you like that i like that i like
that a lot i love the idea of of playing
him in the next world championship and
originally i just i was sure that i
wanted to announce right after the
tournament
the match that this was it i'm done i'm
not playing the next one
but this lit a fire under me so that
made me think you know
this actually motivates me and i just
wanted to get it out there for several
reasons to create more hype about the
candidates
to like sort of motivate myself a little
bit maybe motivate him
also obviously i wanted to give people
and people a heads up for the candidates
that
you might be playing for more than
more than first place like normally the
candidates is
it's first place or best it's like the
world championship um
yeah and and then
so nakamura was one of many people who
just didn't believe me
which is fair
because i've talked before about not not
necessarily wanting
to to defend again
but i never like talked as concretely or
was as serious as this time so he simply
didn't believe me
and he was very vocal about that
and he said nobody believed me no no no
players which may or may and not have
been true
and then yeah he lost he lost the last
game and he didn't
didn't qualify
but to answer the question
no i'd already at that point decided
that i wouldn't wouldn't play
i would have liked it less
if he had
if he had not lost the last round but
the decision was but the decision was
already um was already made